- Well say hi to Young Dylan.
Have y'all met before?
- We have never met before.
I just want y'all to know that,
10 minutes ago
- What happened?
- I got a call from my
14 year old daughter,
to let me know,
this young man is a good friend of hers.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh, what?
- Yes.
- [Steven] Yes.
- Now, I just want y'all
to know that as a dad,
when you see a, a, a cute kid like this,
and you get a call from
your 14 year old daughter
10 minutes before you're
supposed to meet him,
and that's the first time
you ever heard his name,
that makes you very suspicious.
- Makes you nervous.
- We'll be talking later.
- I got you, I got you, I got you.
- Seems like in good
hands. He's in good hands.
Well, Steven,
- Yes.
- What are you ... this has
to be my first question.
- [Steven] Yes.
- What do you have against
the Dallas Cowboys, sir?
(audience laughs)
- [Steven] Kelly
- We're America's team.
- Just want you to know that
for years I've been a fan of your music,
(Kelly laughs)
but I do think it's
important to point this out.
- Okay.
- Do you have to walk around,
like you the champion when
y'all haven't won since 1995?
- Yes. I know. Isn't it crazy?
- Dang.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Who's
your favorite team?
- Pittsburgh Steelers.
- Why are you even talking right now?
- No real life.
- Like why are you even?
- Because the Steelers won
a Super Bowl more recently
than the Cowboys did.
- Me personally-
- But they're not America's team.
Okay. So congrats.
(Kelly laughs)
No, I do wanna say this.
I wanna keep it serious for a minute.
- Beautiful studio.
- Congrats on this.
- Thank you so much.
- This is incredible.
- [Steven] Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly Clarkson] And
- [Steven] Thank you.
- I love,
I love that like it's not...
I think for me, an outsider
just like getting into sports
(indistinct) the world.
I was like, oh, it's probably gonna be
like a lot to do with sports,
but this is like, you, this is your life.
And this is like incredibly
helpful for a lot of people,
- Yeah.
- That will connect to this message,
unfortunately, some of it. And,
why now?
Why did you feel like it
was important now to do it?
- It was time.
I couldn't write it years ago,
when a lot of people were
clamoring for me to write about it
because I promised my
mother who passed away
after a long battle of Cancer in 2017.
I promised her I would
never write the book,
until she passed away because
she made me make that promise.
'Cause she knew that the book
would be a celebration for her.
But inevitably, by celebrating her
I had to talk about
what she had to endure.
And most of the things she
had to endure was caused
by my father, which means I
would have to tell that story.
And my mother was incredibly private,
didn't want her business out
in the street or anything.
But she knew in telling my story,
that's what I was going
to talk about with her.
The title of the book is dedicated to her
because my mother was as
straight of a shooter,
as you possibly can get.
- I think my, I think my
mother would've appreciated
a heads up on "Because
of You". (Kelly Chuckles)
- [Steven] Yes.
- One of my songs.
- That's right. (indistinct)
- But you come from your own perspective,
your own life.
But I think that that's
very respectful, but also,
really cool to give her blessing too.
Because a lot of people, I feel like,
like I'm the youngest
child in my family, right.
- So am I.
- So I learn from watching
the older ones like,
what I should maybe and should not do.
- Absolutely.
- So I think it's really
important to be open like this
if you're able, if you're
capable of doing that
- Well, you could be open
but there has to be a higher
purpose other than yourself.
You want to be motivational
and inspirational.
There's a lot of people
out there, young and old,
all ethnicities,
that go through their
trials and tribulations.
And you feel, especially
in this day and age
with mental health being such
a big issue and what have you,
you see a lot of people
that are inclined to give up
because they feel they see no light
at the end of the tunnel.
And what I wanted to let people know,
that no matter what
obstacles are out there
standing in your path,
no matter how daunting
the task appears to be,
you can overcome.
Put your head down,
focus the way that you need to focus.
And remember, there's
always people around you
willing to help you,
if you are willing to help yourself.
Don't ever think the
world that we live in,
there's no support.
There's always people.
We are all God-fearing individuals.
We are children of God.
Everybody understands,
that if you are willing
to do things for yourself
there's always gonna be
somebody that comes along
that's willing to give you a helping hand.
And all you need is that
little oomph, that little push.
And you can propel
yourself to new heights.
Make no mistake about it.
- Absolutely.
- (Audience cheers)
Absolutely.
Wait, okay, so the big
game is this Sunday.
- [Steven] Yes.
- I'm aware, I think you're
going for the Eagles down there.
Young Dylan. Okay.
- You know, you know.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay. Whatever.
- He's got other problems
to deal with after the show.
After the show, He's got other problems.
- I'm going for the Kansas City Chiefs
because they have great initials.
That's why I'm doing it.
- You know, listen, it's
gonna be a great Super Bowl
because Patrick Mahomes
is something special,
he's something sensational.
And so is Travis Kelce.
I mean, we talk so much
about Patrick Mahomes
but Travis Kelce,
is one of the best titans
in the history of football.
He is phenomenal.
And he's a future Hall
of Famer as well. So,
they're gonna have something
to say about the outcome.
But I think when you look at the Eagles
there are no weak spots.
- They have a great record. Yeah.
- There are no weak spots.
It's hard to imagine
the Philadelphia Eagles,
they could lose, but I
wouldn't bet against them.
- All right.
I'm going to, for fun.
- Okay.
Okay. How much money are you betting?
- I don't know. You wanna make a bet?
- All right, you betting
dinner or something like that?
Well, what bet you want?
I'm willing to...
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay. Okay.
- I'll bet Kelly Clarkson.
- Okay. Wait, wait, wait.
- Wait, wait, wait. Wait.
- All right. I'll do that.
I'll do that
- If the Chiefs,
If the Chiefs win,
- Okay.
- you have to come on here and say,
you love the Dallas Cowboys.
- [Audience] Oo.
- And if the Eagles win,
I have to come on your
show and do something.
- [Steven] That's right.
- Embarrassing.
- Well, let's do it this way.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay.
- I'll take that bet.
- Okay.
- [Steven] Now,
- Okay. What do I have to do?
- If the Eagles win this Super Bowl,
- [Kelly Clarkson] Uh-huh.
- You don't have to be a song.
- Okay.
- I want you to sing a tune dedicated
to Stephen A. Smith, the straight shooter.
- (Kelly laughs)
(Audience cheers)
- I'll take it.
I'll take it.
Oh my God. Come on Chiefs!
Do this for me!
Anyway, Steven A's New
York Times bestseller
Straight Shooter: A Memoir's out now.
Y'all gotta check it out.
And you can also see him mornings on ESPN
as the host of First Take.
Be sure to check out his podcast,
Know Mercy with Steven A. Smith
wherever you get your podcast.